sophia loren naturellement présidente du
jury ce à quoi ne s'attendait sûrement
pas il y a dix ans lors de sa première
est timide apparition à cannes tout ce
rassemblement bien sûr pour aller voir
des films le premier à avoir réellement
frappé l'opinion a pour titre la
religieuse
plus exactement car on n'est jamais
assez précis suzanne simonin la
religieux de tony diderot pointe à la
vigne pensionnat de jeunes filles
s'abstenir son réalisateur jacques
rivette sa vedette anna karina anna
karina est cet étrange petit animal
médine danemark au teint de caviar blanc
à l'oeil d'aquavit bleus si longtemps
considéré comme une animatrice de films
d'amateurs favorisée par le hasard et
qui vient d'un seul coup de prouvé
qu'elle avait sa place parmi les
meilleures actrices de sa génération
mais ne nous laissons pas égarer sur des
chemins profane
rencontrant jacques rivette séminaristes
de l'athéisme et confesseur doué d'une
religieuse qui n'a pas fini de faire
couler de l'encré bénite ou non
en somme la religieuse si on peut dire
c'est votre première vraie chance sur le
plan du contact avec le public oui oui
il s est tiré comme chacun sait la
romandie drôme mais tout le monde n'a
pas eu hydro notamment la religieuse que
raconte diderot dans ce livre en deux
mots c'est l'histoire d'une jeune fille
et ça se passe au xviiie siècle
c'est un c'est à dire exactement à
l'époque ou diderot avait écrit le livre
à dire en 1760
c'est l'histoire d'une jeune fille que
ses parents force à entrer en religion
force à devenir religieuse contre son
gré non pas que cette jeune fille n'est
pas la foi mais simplement parce que là
pas envie de passer sa vie dans un
couvent et le film enfin le roman plutôt
et le film parfitt c'est donc l'histoire
de cette jeune fille on expose d'abord
pourquoi comment elle est obligée
finalement de accepter d'entrer au
couvent et ensuite le l'histoire et
surtout fait des rapports successifs de
suzanne simonin avec les trois
supérieurs qui représentent chacune une
sort une forme différente de la vie
monastique fin d'une des directions
extrême que peut prendre la vie
monastique se sont encore sur trois
postulation pour employer un mot un peu
prétentieux outre trois des postulations
que que peut prendre la vie du couvent
est-ce que sincèrement on va vous
considérez comme un homme à scandales
qui aiment pas forcément le scandale
mais le canular qui va loin
le besoin de choquer l'opinion est ce
que vous êtes quand même une sorte
je ne pense pas du tout enfin évidemment
il est évident quand on fait un film on
ne fait jamais dans l'intention faire
quelque chose de complètement innocent
toute oeuvre d'art a toujours vingt
oeuvres d'art dans toute oeuvre qui
cette boutique et said est une oeuvre
d'art essayent aussi d'être une oeuvre
qui provoquera plus ou moins le
spectateur ou le lecteur qui le portera
qui entrera en contact avec lui en
essayant d'aller le chercher dans ses
retranchements mais enfin ce n'est pas
facile je crois que ça peut être fait
sans pour cela a suscité des scandales
gigantesque et là nous n'avons pas du
tout cherché le scandale on a simplement
cherché à mettre sur pellicule
un sujet qui posait un certain nombre de
questions assez passionnante et un peu
bruyant d'une femme en même temps très
très sereinement donc à passer vous des
néo religieuse qui ne sont pas celles de
diderot et moi je connais très peu de
religieux et de religieuses
j'en ai davantage rencontrés depuis que
j'ai fait le film auparavant
vos rapports avec l heure était d'être
quel ordre ça tu sois fouettée des
rapports de discussions au sujet du film
et ils ont été extrêmement courtois et
même assez agréable justement l'occasion
rencontrer
par exemple pour un débat qui avait été
fait par un hebdomadaire une religieuse
qui avec laquelle nous avons parlé de ce
sujet en termes très serein et ce
qu'elle m'a dit m'a semblé tout à fait
passionnant vous savez quand même qu'il
y avait religieuse qui n'est pas sage
amené rabais qui sait vous là mais ça je
n'ai jamais douté de toute façon ce film
je crois en attaque
absolument pas les religieuses
contrairement aux bruits que l'on veut
faire courir ils n'attaquent même pas la
religion
ils l'attaquent insère une certaine
société qui est celle du xviiie siècle
la tacc un certain état de fait qui en
principe est aujourd'hui complètement
dépassé et il est évident que il met en
cause
au-delà de cette société au delà de cet
état de fait
il met en cause les fondements mêmes de
la vie monastique mais les met en cause
dans des termes qui me semble-t-il sont
des termes extrêmement nobles sont les
termes de réflexion et non pas des
termes de satire ou de critique
bassement anticlérical brut où on est en
droit de se demander quelle est la
justification profond de la vie
claustral c'est une question que
n'importe quel homme et tendre à se
poser que le chrétien lui même est en
droit de se poser est ce que je peux
vous demander si vous croyez en dieu
pour le moment